we're gonna play a game called brussels
sprouts so let me show you how to play
we're gonna start with a couple
crosses
and here's what we do so on player one's
turn
they can connect any two of these free
ends so player one might go like that
and then you need to put a slash through
the curve you've just drawn to create
two new ends like this so that would be
one player's turn and then player two
would go player two might connect to
this end and this end and draw a slash
through
and then it'll be player one's turn
again
player one might do
this
you can't draw through an edge that's
already there so another turn might look
like this
and the game goes on like that
alternating player one and player two so
the player that wins is going to be the
last person that makes a legal move so
at some point if there's no more moves
that you can make then the other player
will win
uh you want to play
i'll give it a go maybe we'll use some
colors yes i'll play blue you play red
okay brady is red
um so why don't you start okay
i will fight that
okay i am going to do this
so this isn't really a fair fight
because i'm really good at brussels
sprouts are you good at it yeah you've
got a good strategy have you yes
copying me i see um i am going to do
this
i will play through
the middle here
i'll do this one
i'll do
this
yeah you lost i'm sorry uh you shouldn't
feel too bad about losing because as i
said i'm really good at brussels sprouts
and actually it's not really a game it's
more of a mathematical trick so no
matter how you would have played i claim
that this game of brussels sprouts was
always going to have eight moves so
because i had you go first you were
always going to lose because the number
of moves was even so player 2 would make
the last legal move so i want to show
you how we know that there's always
eight moves because it's really cool
okay so let's look at this picture that
we have our finished game of brussels
sprouts so i'm going to do something i'm
just going to make these crosses a
little bigger so they're easier to see
so i'm just going to fatten them up a
little bit
and i'm going to call these dots
vertices let's see did i get them all i
did so this kind of picture that we have
here where we have dots that are
vertices and edges connecting them
where the edges aren't crossing over
each other that's what's called a planar
graph and planar graphs we have this
cool mathematical fact so for any
connected planar graph like this one
the number of vertices minus the number
of edges plus the number of faces is
always equal to two
so this is like a really
yeah
sorry that's not a factorial although
two factorials too so we'd be okay
either way
um
it's uh so i'm enthusiastic about this
fact because it's really cool and it's
useful in lots of different things it's
called the euler characteristic
oil yeah so he did a lot of things
including this so we have this fact for
all planar graphs and i claim that we
can use this to study the game of
brussels sprouts so shall we do it so
let's say that we have a game of
brussels sprouts and it ends after
m
moves okay so this is just going to be
the number of moves until the end of the
game and i'm going to try to show that
that number has to be eight so if we're
going to use the euler characteristic we
need to count some things
so we need to count the number of
vertices edges and faces so at the end
of the game i want to count the number
of vertices the number of edges and the
number of faces okay so let's figure it
out when we started the game we had just
these two crosses like this so we had
two vertices at the beginning now what
happens when we make a move so the first
move we connected two of these ends and
we put a slash through that creates a
new vertex so we started with two of
them
but every time we do a move we get
another one so if we have m it moves we
have two plus m of the vertices that
makes sense okay so now i need to count
edges
so let's look at our moves again so
when i make a move
i'm drawing an edge but then remember i
cut it in half
so actually i drew two edges
we started with no edges in the
beginning when we started the game there
were nothing connecting our vertices so
we had zero edges at the beginning and
on each turn we created two
so at the end we have two times the
number of turns
now faces is the trickiest one so let's
look back at our picture here of our
completed game of brussels sprouts so
when we count faces i should have
mentioned earlier that when you count
faces what is a face it's these regions
that are bounded by the edges except
that we also count all of the outside as
one of the faces so over here i need to
count these faces so if we look at the
picture at the end of the game
every face has one free end in it you
know if it had two friends in it the
game wouldn't be over because somebody
could just connect those two ends so we
can only have one free end at the end of
the game
so
each face has one of those ends in it
and those things are actually easier to
count so instead of counting the number
of faces i'll just notice that's the
same
as the number of free ends
tina how do we know there can't be an
end state in which there's a face with
no free ends in it yeah you have to
think a little bit about how the faces
are created so maybe we should look at
like this partially
done one how are the faces created well
we get faces when we
add an edge
and a slash and so every time we're
closing off one of those faces we're
automatically getting a little free end
inside it so there never exists a face
that doesn't have one of those ends in
it so we just need to know there can't
be more than one
okay so we count the number of free ends
and why is that easier to count well
at the beginning of the game how many
did we have so we had four on each of
our little crosses so we started with
eight of them
on each turn you use up two of them
right we use up these two they're not
free anymore
but
we create two more so after one turn
there are still eight
and the same thing is true after every
other turn we use up two of them but we
make two more so we use up two of them
but we make two more
so there are always if you count we
still have eight and in fact we always
are going to have eight so the number of
free ends is eight which means our faces
have to be eight so maybe we should have
done this one as an example so in this
example for instance if we count
vertices there are one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten vertices
and i'm supposed to subtract the number
of edges
there are one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten fifteen sixteen
edges
and i'm supposed to add the number of
faces so these faces are the regions so
it's one two three four five six
seven
but then i also count everything outside
the graph as a region so eight
and then we get two like we were
supposed to
okay so let's let's do the euler
characteristic so i'm supposed to do the
number of vertices minus the number of
edges plus the number of faces two plus
m is the number of vertices
minus the number of edges
plus we had eight faces and it has to be
equal to two euler told us that
so what do i have i have ten minus m is
equal to two
the number of moves is eight
we just showed that player two always
wins but what if you had insisted that
you wanted to go second well i still
could have won
because i could what would you have done
i would have started with three crosses
instead of two so if you start with
three
then the game ends after 13 moves
and the cool thing about brussels
sprouts is that if we start with n
crosses
the game ends
after
five n minus two moves
and it's the exact same argument we just
did just we add another variable to for
the number of crosses
so whenever we start with an even number
of crosses player two wins and with an
odd number of crosses player one wins
so what i recommend is you ask somebody
do you want to play brussels sprouts and
you put two down
and they'll say sure and then you say do
you want to go first or second
and if they say um you know i want to go
second then i just say oh since we
already did two crosses let's add a
third one and we'll play with three
people don't notice because the game
seems like it should have strategy to it
so
people mostly
are focusing on the strategy and not
assuming that i'm starting them with a
losing situation